president biden is in the tough spot
tonight trying to balance his
energy policy with the need to get
support from progressives
it has to do with the president's plan
to give tax breaks
to producers of nuclear power
correspondent rich edson joins us with
specifics tonight good evening rich
good evening brad and the biden
administration appears ready to back a
major federal boost to the american
nuclear industry as part of the
president's aggressive climate goal
of carbon-free power by 2035.
the doe not has not historically
subsidized plants but i think this is a
moment to
consider we're not going to be able to
achieve our climate goals
if our nuclear power plants shut down we
have to find
ways to keep them operating the nuclear
industry faces rising costs
aging infrastructure competition from
other energy sources
and political opposition there are plans
to close reactors at two nuclear plants
in illinois this year
new york state's indian point shut last
week and only one reactors come online
in the past 20 years
though two new reactors are under
construction in georgia
nuclear power accounts for about 20
percent of american electricity
generation and more than half the
country's emissions-free electricity
democratic senator joe manchin chairs
the senate energy committee
in a letter to the president he writes
quote i urge you to take action
to preserve our existing nuclear fleet
and prevent further closures
i believe the federal government must
use all the tools it has
to protect this vile resource some
environmentalists argue that depending
on nuclear will only delay the
development of renewable sources like
the
dropping costs for wind and solar some
progressive democrats oppose nuclear
that includes
senator elizabeth warren she has said
that she wants to phase out nuclear
power by 2035.
senator bernie sanders green new deal
pledge says quote we know that the toxic
waste byproducts of nuclear plants are
not worth the risks of the technology's
benefit
we will not rely on any false solutions
like nuclear though if the white house
and congressional leaders decide to
support nuclear despite these objections
it is still unclear how much they're
willing to spend on these tax credits
right back to you we'll follow this one
rich thanks hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else